I visited Cuba and I brought a camera  crew and some production people and we  went out and we spent four days shooting  round the clock pretty much all around  Havana had a fantastic experience the  people are absolutely amazing yeah the  the chemistry they really are they're  just incredible people and I'm very much  looking forward to to everyone sharing  in my joy at getting to see this  incredible City we we actually have a  photograph here which we haven't shown  yet that's me I just was walking around  this is not staged it looks staged I was  just walking around in that ridiculous  linen suit and I came across these  amazing street performers in Havana and  I started dancing with them and we all  danced together for I think the better  part of 24 hours and so it was really  fun look for that it'll be a special  show we do called Conan in Cuba  Wednesday March 4  [Applause]  you